as it turns out Eric and Donald Trump
jr. might be even worse at business than
their father because let's be honest
Donald Trump has gone through so many
bankruptcies that the man could probably
recite you every bankruptcy law in this
country but his sons Eric and Donald Jr
are even more incompetent than the man
who bankrupted casinos according to a
new report Eric and Donald Jr who are
now running the Trump Organization keep
forgetting to pay the property taxes on
the buildings and resorts that the Trump
Organization operates this failure to
pay on time because they are paying
theirs not paying on time has resulted
in sixty one thousand eight hundred
dollars in excessive fees penalties and
missed discounts for the Trump Boys
here's what's happening this story is
funny because these two men we see
they're buffoons anytime they're on TV
or on Twitter but now we get to see it
in an actual report about their business
dealings Trump properties from coast to
coast all the way from California to
South Florida to New York to Chicago are
not paying their property taxes on time
and again those two men are running it
so here's what's happened we have all of
these experts that have looked into this
and they're baffled they can't figure
out why they're not paying their taxes
after all most major corporations in
this country actually have automated
programs and reminders that are set up
to pay these property taxes because they
arrive at a predictable time every year
they are a predictable amount every year
and you pay them every year at the same
time but these Trump boys are so
dysfunctional that they have made every
facet of the Trump Empire just as
dysfunctional again they're eventually
paying their tax bills they're just not
doing it by the due date resulting in
additional fines for them and I find
this hilarious but what's even more
hilarious is it the Washington Post dug
into this they got the tax
it's verifiable and yet this was the
response the vetted member of the Trump
Organization had when asked why they're
not paying their taxes on time she said
we have always paid our real estate
taxes on a timely basis and to say
otherwise is totally disingenuous and
she said this with a straight face to
the people who had the tax documents in
their hands it said no no you didn't but
she just like everybody else we've seen
work for Donald Trump lied to their
faces light over the phone and said
you're wrong you're fake news you're
fake news it's insane I guess that's a
prerequisite to be a part of the Trump
administration or the Trump Organization
is that you have to be an absolute liar
but it does bring a smile to my face to
see that Eric and Donald Jr are
absolutely destroying this company by
making it overall as stupid as those two
are unfair and cousins and for David
Pakman we'll be right back
today's program is made possible in part
by fruit or which is a social
forecasting game for your phone where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
go on the app find a future event you
feel confident enough about to make a
prediction and make a bet on the outcome
that you think will happen using the
apps in game fake currency if your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points you can compete with others
who are making their own prediction to
see who is the best forecaster there's
no real world money or cryptocurrency
involved the fun of but--or is
interacting with others and showing the
world your skills at predicting the
future will Democrats take the White
House house this year will Trump run for
re-election will Trump ever build the
wall you can go ahead and make your
predictions show off your forecasting
skills and there are also monthly
competitions and prizes for top
forecasters and I'm on foote or you can
wager on my predictions you can also
browse the politics category for lots of
interesting questions to go to fruit or
calm to sign up and make forecast it's
free it's on Android and iOS
as well as on web browsers and it's
spelled fut you you are calm